seventy-eight is 15% of what number so
there's some unknown number out there
and if we take 15% of that number we
will get 78 so let's just call that
unknown number X and we know that if we
take 15% of X so if we take 15% of X so
multiply X by 15% we will get we will
get 78 and now we just literally have to
solve for x now 15% mathematically you
can deal directly with percentages but
it's much easier if it's written as a
decimal and we know that 15% is the same
thing as 15 per 100 that's literally
percent cent means 100 which is the same
thing as 0.15 this is literally 1500s 15
hundredths so we could rewrite this as
0.15 times some unknown number times X
times X is equal to is equal to 78 and
now we can divide both sides of this
equation by 0.15 to solve for X so you
divide the left side by 0.15 and I'm
literally picking 0.15 to divide both
sides because that's what I have out
here in front of the X so if I'm
multiplying something by 0.15 and then I
divide it by 0.15 I'll just be left with
an X here that's the whole motivation if
I do it to the left-hand side I have to
do it to the right-hand side
0.15 these cancel out and I get X X is
equal to 78 divided by 0.15 now we have
to figure that out what that is if we
had a calculator pretty straightforward
but let's actually work it out so we
have 78 divided by and we're going to
going to be at some decimal number so
it's going to be some decimal number
it's going to be larger than 78 but
let's figure out what it ends up being
so let's store some zeros out there it's
not going to be a whole number and we're
dividing it by 0.15
0.15 now so to simplify things let's
multiply both this numerator and this
denominator by 100 and that's so that
0.15 becomes 15 so 0.15 times 100 is 15
we're just moving the decimal two to the
right let me put that in a new color
right there that's where our decimal
goes and let me erase the other one so
we don't get confused and if we did that
for the 15 we also have to do that for
the 78 so if we move the decimal two to
the right one two it becomes seventy
eight hundred seventy eight hundred or
seven thousand eight hundred so one way
to think about it 78 divided by 0.15 is
the same thing as seven thousand eight
hundred divided by 15 multiplying the
numerator and the denominator by 100 so
let's figure out what this is 15 does
not go into seven fifteen so you could
go zero times and you could do all of
that or you could just say okay that's
not going to give us anything so then
how many times does 15 go into 78 so
let's think about it 15 goes into 60
four times it'll go it's 15 times 5 is
75 that looks about right
so we say 5 times 5 times 15 5 times 5
is 25 put the 2 up there
5 times 1 is 5 plus 2 is 7
75 you subtract 78-75 is 3 bring down a
0 bring down a 0 15 goes into 30 exactly
2 times 2 times 15 is 30 subtract no
remainder bring down the next zero we're
still to the left of the decimal point
the decimal point is right over here if
we write it up here which we should it's
right over there so we have one more
place to go so we bring down this next
zero 15 goes into 0 zero times zero
times 15 is zero subtract no remainder
so 78 divided by 0.15 is exactly 520 so
X is equal to 520 so 78 is 15 percent of
520 and if we want to use some of the
terminology that you might see in a math
class
the 15% is obviously the percent this is
the percent that is the percent 520 or
the what number before we figured out it
was 520 that's what we're taking the
percentage of this is sometimes referred
to as the base that is the base and then
when you take fit some percentage of the
base you get what sometimes refer to as
the amount so in this circumstance 78
would be the amount you could view it as
the amount is the percentage of the base
but we were able to figure that out
it's nice to know those if that's used
that's the terminology used in your
class but the important thing is to be
able to just answer this question and it
makes sense because 15% is a very small
fraction so 78 is a is or it's a small
percentage if 78 is a small percentage
of some number that means that number
has to be pretty big has to be pretty
big and our answer it gels with that
this looks about right 78 is about 15%
of or it is exactly 15% of 520